some love scenes transcend even
circumstantial weirdness and are so
painfully awkward in and of themselves
that you'd be embarrassed to watch them
alone much less with other people
luckily the lovemaking experts here at
looper are ready to help you steer
around the train wrecks with this look
at some love scenes that went way too
far gone girl is a few grisly scenes but
the one that takes a cake isn't
doubtfully the scene where a me brutally
slaughters a hapless love interest in
order to frame her husband for the crime
it's sickeningly violence and far too
disturbing to actually show you so
instead here's some footage of a
hospital patient being cuddled back to
life by adorable kittens trust us it's
for your own good second only to that
blue naked guy the weirdest thing in
Watchmen just might be the big love
scene between superheroes Nite Owl and
Silk Spectre after trying once before
and failing with night Sal couldn't
perform a superhero duties the duo went
out and beat up a bunch of crooks which
gave them the possess a needed to do the
deed it's meant to be commentary on the
kinky intersection of violence and
romance for people who dress up in
fetish gear to fight crime but it's
actually just off-putting
especially the choice of Leonard Cohen's
Hallelujah as the scenes soundtrack what
the heck were they thinking the 40 year
old virgin consists almost entirely of
one uncomfortable scene after another
it's about a bunch of boorish dudes who
work at an electronics store and decide
to help their nerdy colleague Andy
nailed down his first intimate
experience that advice is disastrous as
shown clearly in the aborted love scene
between Andy and Beth an overly
dominating hooker who nearly initiates
Andy into all sorts of things he's not
ready for before his friends Bailey
Mouse foes call for him and for the
audience for the Twilight Saga Breaking
Dawn Part 1 at the filmmakers run into
trouble with the long-awaited moment of
physical intimacy between the human
Bella and a super-powered bitter vampire
Edward star Kristen Stewart explained
the resulting mess to Harper's Bazaar UK
saying it had to be transcendent and
otherworldly inhuman better sex and you
can possibly ever imagine and we were
like how do we live up to that it was
agony which sucks because I wanted it to
be so good that's how we all felt about
the entire series so you're in good
company Kristen James Cameron CGI world
of Avatar was so different so alien that
even the act of physical intimacy was
something to behold of course that
doesn't take into consideration whether
or not it was something anyone actually
wanted to behold here's the main thing
on the
and Pandora making love is basically
just plug and play thanks says Navi
avatar human Marine Jake Scully can get
busy with actual Navi female Neytiri of
course that means connecting the
tendrils on the ends of their braids to
fully experience one another the most
intimate of ways and let's not forget
this all goes down in a purple jellyfish
forest thanks James Cameron I'm the king
of the world the 2003 megaflip jelly
it's one of the most renowned critical
and box-office turkeys of all time and a
big part of that is the embarrassingly
squishy love scene between Ben Affleck
and Jennifer Lopez it's turkey time
rumor has it that the studio forced to
claim director Martin pressed to change
the film in order to showcase real-life
romance between Lopez and Affleck if so
that was a terrible idea so bad in fact
that breasts retired from filmmaking
entirely as a result and after watching
this love scene we totally get why
Howard the Duck is a lot of things for
instance it was the first bomb of George
Lucas's career and it's the only movie
or at least the only mainstream American
comedy to feature of romantic trysts
between a female rock star and a
man-sized anthropomorphic duck let's go
for it mr. macho
you're so incredibly soft and cuddly
Howard has since being reintroduced in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but so far
there's been no sign of any romance for
Howard
fingers crossed we'd never see this
again the 1993 sci-fi satire demolition
man had an ambitious and bizarre view of
what the future would be like Sylvester
Stallone's character John Spartan wakes
from a cryogenic freeze to find that
peace reigns and also that people make
love using virtual reality helmets while
follows a ridiculous scene where Sandra
Bullock's police lieutenant Huxley
attempts to seduce him in the clumsiest
way possible including playing the theme
from The Love Boat as an aphrodisiac as
weird images jolt through his mind
needless to say Spartan is not amused or
a rouse what do you say we just do it
the old-fashioned way
Oh disgusting you mean check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more loop of videos but your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]